why is a set of candidates at least from
my perspective so weak one aspect to
this which I think is more of a
socio-cultural thing which I've recently
read about to some degree is the job
actually turns off the people who would
be best at it because of what you need
to do to become president
and it includes
all but completely abandoning your
existing day-to-day life job which you
may depend on and family to some degree
um it's horribly uh negative as we
already talked about
and at the end of all of that you either
lose and then have to rebuild and maybe
you're not in a position to be able to
do that or you win and then now you've
got four years of being one of the most
hated people no matter how good a job
you do so I think by its nature it turns
off a lot of people that would otherwise
be good